blaring on Capitol Hill in the battle
over impeachment it comes as House
Democrats unveil a resolution outlining
the next chapter in their inquiry that
could lead to public hearings a vote is
set for this Thursday the White House
just responded in a new statement
calling the impeachment process a quote
illegitimate sham meantime Republicans
venting frustration over leaked
testimony from today's witness White
House official Lieutenant Colonel
Alexander vind men been men saying that
he twice raised concerns about president
Trump's phone call with Ukraine
Republicans going after house Intel
Committee Chairman Adam Schiff accusing
him of blocking bin Minh from answering
certain questions the resolution that
was filed today in and of itself
according to speaker Pelosi affirms the
soviet-style process that's been going
on and continues to deny due process an
equal access to both sides chairmanship
has prevented the witness from answering
certain questions we have during the
deposition
now he's directing witnesses not to
answer questions that he doesn't want
the witness to answer if they're asked
by Republicans all right that's
problematic Kennedy what do you think
about what's going on in there
i I know that the Lieutenant Colonel has
been vilified and I think that you know
he has served his country and this is
what's interesting about the president
because he is such a non-traditional
thinker it's it's like someone who goes
to a loosey-goosey progressive school
all of a sudden trying to fit in at
Annapolis and they're going to have a
very difficult plea here and the
president kind of has an extended
plebian in terms of Washington protocol
this is a man who has served for decades
in the Armed Forces
and if you read the list of his
accomplishments it is very very stunning
and so for him I bet his his protocol
Lane is pretty straightforward and you
know it very systematic and the
president's is more like a series of
wild tangents and so the way the
President operates may not make sense to
this person and you know hearing what he
heard he may have felt that the
president crossed the line have
Democrats through their leaks and
opacity proven that that line so far is
impeachable I don't think so yet and
that's what's pragmatic I don't think we
should be vilifying this person though
because he does have an interesting
personal history and he has growing the
uniform and served honorably works right
across the hall in the White House which
I do think is it fun final very little
trust wins that's all I thought the guy
was okay but if he has twins Nancy
Pelosi is now codified in this
resolution which we've seen today do you
you know as a Democrat do you have a
concern that this could go down the
wrong road because you know you look at
Newt Gingrich and you look at what
happened with Clinton impeachment it
didn't end up working very well in the
coming election oh I you know look I
think that President Clinton you know
his numbers went up actually during the
impeachment hearing yeah and I think it
damaged Al Gore going into mm oh but I
do think that there is a sense here that
in fact Democrats then went on to
capture both the House the Senate and of
course come back I just think that you
know they feel they have an obligation
to uphold the Constitution which is that
the Congress is an equal branch of
government responsible for oversight and
responsible for this very difficult
impeachment process so I I mean I think
they didn't need to do this but they
have done it and they're holding now to
the same lines that applied in previous
impeachment hearings I would just want
to add one thing to what Kennedy was
saying with this guy Alex Vinland
previously Republicans were saying oh
this is hearsay nobody actually was
there well ventolin was actually
listening to the call now Trump is
saying I don't know how could he have
listened to the call but Finland says he
was on the call and to question his
loyalty I mean I want to read something
here a lot of people are from David
French who's a conservative columnist
and he said the sheer number of American
French a trump fost will insult slander
and mock for the sake of their corrupt
draft-dodging Dear Leader is just the
style yeah but but French has been never
been the same since the election so oh
yeah what
here's my point it's not about it's not
about Vin de Vin de man it's about the
fact that he was concerned and being
concerned doesn't mean something
happened right you can everything since
Trump has been president
everybody's been concerned about this
that concerned about is his personality
concerned about his foreign policy
actors concerned about North Korea
everything it goes pretty much all right
stock market did not crash we were
concerned about that so just being
concerned about something isn't enough
so that's not a that's not to denigrate
this man what I'm saying is it's ok to
be concerned but concern doesn't mean
something happen here's the reality the
media is running this operation we will
not see the end of it you will never
know the truth because they're
controlling this thing and you can see
the naked ambition happen today because
we had such good news
without back daddy being killed that all
of a sudden this happens is it's just
their way of this is their new drug
Russia was our old drug this is their
new drug I'm with Gregg I don't really
care to hear how someone feels about
Donald Trump's phone call the tick tock
is we have a transcript to inflame
everybody on the daily news cycle we
have the transcript we know what happens
if this guy who's working for the
president doesn't like the policy quit
or advise the president differently
don't sabotage him from within and then
for the left to say that oh no you can't
criticize someone that's wearing the
uniform we just had it last week they
went after Tulsi Gabbard questioned her
patriotism
they've savaged Mike Flynn who's worn
the uniform question his patriotism Mike
Pompeo Lindsey Graham the same thing so
you can't have it both ways just because
you wear a uniform doesn't mean you
can't be questioned if someone disagrees
with you yeah what about the fact that
he confirmed what the whistleblower
the transcript but I have to say like
what if he told the whistleblower what
he knew